[Music]
so it's gonna be a crisis or some
metahuman threatening to take the life
that you love we're all living on
borrowed time
as a creature out there with the
strength of ten men getting stronger by
the minute
oh good you're still here
what's going on listen he's under attack
by who
[Music]
to go where Oh
you gotta go
Oh
well come on
biometrics are crashing also picking up
temporal energy readings
his mind has broken passes barrier it's
not just a new timeline he's found it's
billions of them and Barry's mind is
experiencing them all
and all of the buildings to survive this
coming crisis flash
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my flash season 6 episode 3
trailer in a breakdown of all the crisis
on Infinite Earths teasers and scenes
from the last couple of episodes
including arrow season 8 episode 1 so
we'll talk about the flash footage then
I'll talk about all the crisis scenes
we're doing a new DC merch giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best theory
after these weeks episodes about what's
going on during the crossover so we
start with that post credit scene from
the flash season 6 episode 2 blood work
now in what seems like STAR Labs seeing
that his Gollum that he accidentally
created has followed him through the
ventilation shaft Q joke about it being
super easy to break into STAR Labs they
made a couple of jokes about that in
previous seasons because you had a
couple of seasons of the flash we're
villains week-to-week would just waltz
into STAR Labs like it was no big deal
even though you have to go to level 200
on the special elevator just to get to
the control center where they spend most
of their time
STAR Labs is huge you don't always get a
sense for the scale because of the way
they shoot the show in a couple small
hallways and the cortex you only really
start to see it and scenes like Barry
running around the pipeline when he's
trying to enter the Speed Force like
during last week's episode blood work
clearly doesn't know anything about how
his powers work yet it's quite literally
though controlling blood they have a
much more scientific way of explaining
how that works on the show but they get
really crazy with it during the flash
rebirth comic book during the negative
flash story arc the Golem is then seen
getting ready to kill a couple of
nameless henchmen in a warehouse and
then the flash trying to fight him in a
lab that doesn't quite look familiar but
because blood works whole thing is
getting his hands on more dark matter to
perform his experiments the zombified
creature he inadvertently created it
might be doing this for him
unconsciously and just reacting to his
unspoken desires without him realizing
it there was a very negative flash
looking preview of Barry Allen from a
scene that they filmed in a future
episode so early theory that might have
something to do that negative flash
stuff with his ability to zombify people
using their blood in his meta powers but
moving on to the crisis on Infinite
Earths scenes Barry watches his own
death December 10th in the very near
future as a wave of antimatter washes
over all of earth 1 the same way we see
it wash over earth 2
during arrow season 8 episode 1 so I
should also say careful for spoilers
from arrow season 8 episode 1 I'll
discuss the crisis Easter eggs and the
scenes that they address during that TV
show this week here's the breakdown of
all that the show's each week will be
setting up crisis on Infinite Earths so
like there was a scene at the end of
arrow there was a scene during the flash
it's gonna be like that every single
week mostly on the arrow in flash though
the flash this week was all about
showing you what their current end game
looks like before they find a way to
stop the anti-monitor we just got an
official preview of what he looks like
during the crossover he's kind of their
version of a white Walker or the night
king but really he's made to look like
comic book anti-monitor from the new 52
when he's revealed as the möbius
character during the new 52 darkside war
storyline they rewrote his backstory and
made it a little more complex his new
backstory is is that he was this
brilliant scientist born on a planet in
the antimatter universe and he was
seeking to find the source of the
creation of the antimatter universe and
inadvertently discovered the anti-life
equation the thing that Darkseid has
been trying to control in the comics for
years the anti-life equation transformed
him into the version of the anti-monitor
that you see today so he used to look a
little more normal fun fact to his
original name is mobius he created the
mobius chair that Metron of the new gods
has been using this whole time in the
comics he gave it to him willingly
there was an easter egg for mr. miracle
on jay garrick's map on the flash i
don't know if they're gonna get into any
big new god stuff during the crossover
but it would make sense that they would
try to reference that if this is such a
big comic book event that they're doing
during arrow season 8 episode 1 oliver
is actually on earth two on a mission
for the monitor to collect some dwarf
star particles they use the episode is a
big riff on the pilot episode it's meant
to be a big love letter to the fans so
it's all the things from the pilot but
done a very twisted alternate universe
way so Tommy winds up being the dark
Archer Merlyn is married to his mother
so he and Tommy are actually really
brothers on earth to thier version of
Adrian chase has become the hood
since Oliver's father on earth to was
outed as the hood back during flash
season 2 in their version of the arrow
story earth to Oliver died when the
Queens gambit went down it was his
father Robert Queen that was stranded on
can you for five years then came back
and took up the hood the Batman mask in
the intro on Lian Yu replaces the
Deathstroke mask because on their earth
it was Batman who was also stranded with
Oliver's father on Lian Yu
Adrienne Chase also says that Batman was
his mentor for a brief period when he
gave him some lessons boys talking to
Oliver at the end of the episode they
barely escaped at the end of the episode
just as the anti-monitor shows up to
destroy earth two's a universe with an
antimatter wave just like you saw in
Barry's flash-forward on the flash
episode two I haven't heard anything
about Jessie quick in Harrison wells
from earth-2 being in this year's
crossover so we'll say RI p tentatively
to them but it's always possible because
she's a speedster that she was able to
get them off planet before the big blast
wave of antimatter caught them press up
in the chat for Earth - they totally
foreshadowed this on the flash episode -
with jay garrick's map of the multiverse
a lot of you noticed this he's been
tracking antimatter events across the
multiverse for the past year in this map
had a giant red arrow pointing to earth
- saying that this is where the next
event was going to happen cue an hour
later on the arrow episode when it
actually does happen they'll be doing
stuff like this on the shows all season
long sort of doing mini crossovers so
I'll cover those in the Easter Egg
videos that I do week to week the map
itself is fantastic it has all kinds of
Easter eggs and a few unknown earths
that they marked with question marks
that I think will probably wind up being
Smallville Superman's earth maybe
Kingdom Come Superman's earth during the
crossover the only reason why they would
put question marks here and show it to
you in a long drawn out scene is just to
tease you for stuff to be revealed later
on most of the other earths that they
have marked here are the ones that we've
traveled to on the flash and previous
crossovers like the freedom fighters
from Earth X over here well as the gray
from the Council of wells over here a
couple more crisis comic book Easter
eggs like this earth that was destroyed
during 1986 the year the comic book
crisis was published they also recently
referenced Wonder Woman being on earth 1
so that means that there is a version of
Wonder Woman on the flash and arrows
earth but because we haven't seen her we
don't know if that's going to be Lynda
Carter classic Wonder Woman or a
different version because they are
trying to get Lynda Carter for this
year's crossover but post all your
theories about how they're going to stop
the anti-monitor
because it won't be exactly like it
happens in the comics and like I said
Oliver is sort of on a quest going
across the multiverse collecting things
that they need to stop him yes I have
heard the rumors about Titans possibly
having a scene during the crossover
they're getting ready to do Nightwing
red hood stuff on Titans so I will do a
video for that sometime soon there's a
bunch of other stuff too like Rick and
Morty that I'll be doing videos for and
Watchmen episode 1 is coming Sunday I'll
be doing weekly videos for that too
those will be Sunday night videos so
look out for that this Sunday
congratulations CUDA you're the giveaway
winner from my last big flash video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details yes
there was a rumor that Lucifer is seen
on set but they haven't officially
announced it so I'm gonna wait to do a
video about him until they confirm it
everybody click here for my flash season
6 episode 2 video and click here for
that flash Batman crossover teaser thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]